[Music]
hello everyone i'm grand master dennis
bush and this
is the game of the week
and this time we are going to peruse the
games
by the legend himself chakriyama medyaro
the first winner i mean the winner of
the first
grand chess tour of the year he actually
had an
astounding streak a winning streak so to
say
which catapulted him in first place
now he didn't really have such a great
event
at the beginning it was sort of sloish
making a couple of draws nothing
extremely
outrageous and i felt
that we should take a look at all those
games
see what differentiated his game
to your regular berlin games that you've
seen
in the other tournaments all right so
let's take a look
le pulasku is the opponent he's facing
he's playing black
knight f3 and d5 just
claiming the center very very
consolidating move
not the aggressive shock moment yard of
play shock used to play
the king's indian
and the grunfeld so both of
these systems and i point that out
because these are aggressive systems
where you need to be resolute
and aggressive in order to succeed so
shock momentum
is capable of playing aggressive chess
but this time he's taking a more
restrained approach
even though he is a hundred points
higher rated
than his romanian opponent e3
e6 c4 and the very next move
by mamedyarov is
nothing special you'd think it doesn't
really
change the whole flow of the game but
actually it does because lupulescu's
plan is the following
get the night out get the pawn to b3
go to bishop b2 if that ever happens
white might actually build an attack for
example
not f6 knight c3
should be 7 b3 here
bishop b2 c5 takes
knight takes queen c2 and often times
what you see is an h4 knight g5
direct attack on the king side
now that is something that mom and dad
not necessarily want
to endure or face so instead he plays
this
very very rare move of bishop e7
which is the fifth or sixth most popular
out there so not at all the main lines
now bishop e7 is not just the move
it gives shakhriyam ahmadyarov extra
options
vhv which he wouldn't have in other
cases
so b3 and here comes the kicker the
knight is not in the way this time
and he can't go bishop f6 now bishop f6
might not be objectively the best move
but it does serve mamedyarov's purpose
he's getting lupulescu out of his
comfort zone
it's already not what he was predicting
to happen this is not the variation
he sort of thought is going to be on the
board
knight c3 knight e7
and these are those interesting moments
in chess when you're facing an idea
that's
novel to you that you've never seen
before
and there are thoughts that
come to your mind should i do what i
would do anyways
should i just get my pieces out should i
go castle quickly or should i punish the
fact
that this bishop has taken the knight's
normal spot which would be on f6
now here lupulesco decides to go bishop
b2
but bishop b2 is sort of admitting okay
you played a move that is not the
standard way of playing but i'm still
going to follow on with my regular plans
but it does turn out
white had this extra option of getting
the bishop to a3
trying to put pressure along this
diagonal
and stopping shakhriyah from playing c5
even if they take you could take with
the bishop
and white has good control
and he has more coverage of the center
squares
now in some sense you can call this
mama jarvis bluff he's saying lupulescu
isn't going to challenge me in
this sub-variation he is just going to
play his casual chess and try to play
from there
so bluff number one is paying off
now you might be wondering okay but
what's the big deal
the display and let's say some other
solids
solid players playing in uh
more consolidated style like knight f6
the one move i mentioned before
well this one already poses questions
for lupulescu
and he does have to waste some time
realizing how to continue on so
what shakhriyat is doing is to putting
pressure
on move 4 already on
white asking questions and
slowly piling it till he crumbles but
let's continue on bishop b2
c5 and that's actually the problem
it allows the black pieces to take the
control
and now even d4 is soon going to be a
threat
queen c2 well not just yet though
because in case of d4 there is knight e4
and this bishop on f6 is
hanging and is not
going to have a easy time
moving around knight b6
all right so let's take a look at this
position and
think about a couple of moves that i
could play here
obviously we'd definitely consider
taking on d5
but that would only strengthen
chakriar's position
getting this mummified bishop out to
either f5 or g4
and in both cases that bishop is going
to be massively strong
so cxd5 is right out here
what else could we do in this position
what would make sense
just if we follow the
all tried and tested methods of playing
chess
well our king is still stuck in the
center
so it's not the happiest piece out there
so it could make sense for us to
try it to try to give it and find it
some safety
and shelter so a move that
would be a consideration is to go bishop
e2
and just prepare castling
bishop d3 would be a little bit pushing
it
black does have some threats as kind of
knight b4 hitting the queen and
the bishop the same time
so especially in these
very unique and closed positions you've
got to be
on the lookout for unusual threats by
the opponent and here mommy giroff does
have
this tricky idea of knight b for
that in other cases wouldn't be as
dangerous so you could even try to go
a3 try avoid that and then you can still
go bishop d3 and if d4
can still go on ip4 and the bishop and
the pawn is under attack
and white is doing quite well
knight a4 and knight a4 is sort of a
step
in the wrong direction
why well it's forcing exchanges
but as we all know exchanges favor the
side with less space
and at the moment it's black who has
pieces that are a bit cramped this
bishop
is crammed on c8 and this f6 bishop
wasn't particularly
as good knight a4 b6
another win for chakri r so you will see
how mama jarvis accumulating his
advantage
he's not just going to outrun and run
the pulaski
off the board he's slowly going to gain
a bit of space
then some more time and then suddenly
it's going to be game over
b6 takes g takes
now to lupulescu's credit these pawns do
get doubled
and that is a benefit c takes d5
okay this is a critical moment so let's
just
think about this for a second how
would we want to take back we've got
three options
seemingly all same value well one of
them is
much less good than the others but
the top two is close to each other close
to be the best
so we've got to make a decision and this
is the critical moment
if you want to play more
of this tank type of chess where
you're not really giving away too much
for your opponent you might be
doing a little bit of provocation as
mamjaro is allowing his doubled pawns
but you still have to be very accurate
because
one little slip and your advantage might
just be gone
so e takes z5 is not great and wasn't
played by
chakri r because as the e pawn moves
the more lonely those double pawns get
those pawns get very lonely
and it's much easier to go after them
with queen b2
and put pressure on the f-pawn so that
kind of leaves us
with knight takes and queen takes
and both knight takes and queen takes
looks good
but queen takes actually thinks about an
important principle
of having everything defended and under
control
if you go knight d5 there is bishop b5
knight e7 and vine might even risk the
biscuit with d4
put pressure on c5 and you
see all those pins working out
for white's favor and all this happened
because you left your knight
undefended so that's why here
shock when four queen takes d5 also
in case of any trouble the e pawn is
there
to block with e5
and just control everything
it takes d5 it is correct though that it
invites the knight of bank but
sometimes you do have to give some
things away
queen h5 and here lupulus google is
knight e4
now knight b5 looks tempting but it
doesn't really do too much there
is this one trick on c7 setting up the
fork
but black can castle
just put the king into safety or do the
little bit more artificial king f8 with
the same idea of getting the king to g7
and just chilling there
so there are some superfluous moves
that lupulescu can go for in this
position
but they really don't have any firepower
behind them
there's only one night and it's not
going to be enough
for success so knight e4
queen g6 again
probing lupulescu trying to provoke
some play and provoking
right to overextend because so far
even if white is just sitting around
he's probably not in danger of being
worse
bishop is not necessarily even the
strongest move but
white can't just go castle let's say
knight g3 and
white is more or less still in the game
nothing to really fear in this situation
so mamadyarov continues
on with being an agent provocateur and
goes queen g6
saying hey you see my queen eyeing yours
yes that's what i want i want a little
bit of drama
and if you go with knight d6 check there
is well you can definitely go king f8
maybe king d7 is a little bit too much
due to knight e4
probably king f8 is even better and
a trade will not do you too much i
will get my pawns all huddled up and
black does have the d4 square under
control
so black is close to being equal and
will have
chances to get even better
and this is the moment when you see mama
jarok taking over
he might be a slightly bit worse
but already lupulescu has to ask some
like has to face some uncomfortable
questions
knight h4 queen h6
knight d6 here knight takes c8
rook takes c8 if you ask me i think
still knight f3 would be a better move
for lupulescu lebelascu is actively
pursuing exchanges and these
trades are no good because
at every trade shock gets closer
to organize his pieces just look at the
position now
this bishop on c8 is still stuck in
there
it will stick take some time for
momagerov to organize it
you can't go bishop b7 due to knight d6
check so it will take some work
queen h6 but he played knight d6 king f8
and to prove my point mahmoud yarov gets
to put his rook on the open
file and not even
move that c8 bishop at all so knight d6
is probably one of the inaccurate moves
here shock vr might be already even
and getting very close to be slightly
better
g3 okay so let's stop here
let's try to observe this a little bit
and realize
which squares will be critical in the
long run
for both sides there are two very
important squares
that both black and white wants to
control
which one of those do you guys think
is the most important one in this game
now yeah d4 obviously is an important
square but there is
always a square close to a weak one
and that's the d1 so this d3
square can be pretty problematic
especially if this knight can hop to
b4 so if the bishop moves there is
potential
ideas of going rook d8 knight b4 and you
take
over everything
so there's actually two big critical
squares
d4 and in some respect b4 although it is
in somewhat with relation of the d3
square
so rd8 basically setting up that idea
he is fortifying the d4 square
and also make sure in case of bishop g2
he has knight b4 hitting the queen and
getting ready to play and knight d3 and
now white
is in big trouble
because he will lose the right to castle
and everything is under a clampdown
so rook d8 bishop e2 now all that
said lupulescu's position is by no means
tragic
his position is fine but
there are some unusual weaknesses
he has to deal with there is a couple of
weaknesses along this diagonal
and the d2 pawn is a backwards one
king g7 a3
so they already figured out that
d4 square is going to be super important
and then the b4 square is the other one
we've got to find a target we've got to
find a target
otherwise it's very difficult to win a
chess game
we already talked about a bit of
lupulascus king side
but it's pretty rock solid over there
it's
a whole mountain of pawns we're
never going to crash through or not
yet f5 f4
seems unlikely to work because we've got
that f4 square covered
so that will leave us to the one and
only target
that mamadorf can go against
which pawn is that
you can't really invade squares by now
because the bishop is controlling all
those
now again this is one of those things
that i always say
you can only attack pawns that are
visible
to you things that are invisible
very very difficult to go after those
so here the strongest move for
shah is rook d6
undermining the d2 pawn so going after
the d2 pawn
preparing the idea of doubling on the d
file
f4 rook d8
and f4 i feel
is useful but you can feel that
white is sort of creating more and more
weaknesses in his position
rook d8 rook d1
any threads by white not really f5
there's always knight e5
and id three ideas that's not something
that black needs to worry about but he
still
wants to make sure that this pawn
structure is fixated
so lupulescu doesn't get overtly
aggressive
now i think here lupulesco is just a bit
too quick to move the knight
i'd still think castling would be much
better
and just wait for a better moment to
move the knight away and defend the d2
pawn
like it's just a better choice
knight f3 knight d5
again simple chess he
put all his rooks on the open file
got the knight in the center castles
okay so
the knights are perfectly placed the
rooks are perfectly placed
but then comes the dilemma of
trying to figure out what lupulusku is
planning to do
so if lupulescu was to move
you've got to consider all sorts of pawn
breaks
and all sorts of tricks and traps
so what would be all those tricky moves
that
mamadarav needs to consider
the couple of moves that are annoying to
deal with for black
it is actually by the way a reversed
hedgehog
a typical reversed hedgehog structure
and in a reverse hedgehog you
always play for brakes
this case is non-different to that
well the e pawn is closer to the center
so black would be happy to trade an
f-bomb for the e-pawn
that would still definitely be
a decent position
for black actually d4 is no good
you want to keep your center pawns if
possible
so one of the typical pawn breaks you
can go for and think about
is b4 indeed b4 ideas is very typical
now black has everything under control
there
but it's still a critical way of playing
and if it's successful it usually
destroys the structure
and the other one is queen bee too so
it's either b4
or queen b2 now as mamadjarov knows
that's not going to happen he will start
working against this idea of queen b2
so queen b2 is on tap
therefore shock plays king g8
king g8 and if you go queen b2 that's
not a check
now you might be wondering why is that
so important
why would you move it away
and not let your opponent check well the
reason you go king g8
now if in case of queen b2
you can make a different move so
let's say you go
rook d7 queen b2 check
king g8 a lot of times you realize i
regret moving my rook
to that square i would have played
anything else but this one
this could run into knight e5
ideas attacking both the rook
and the knight on c6 not ideal right
it's not what we want to have if you go
king g8 they go queen b2
you get the exact same position that
shock getting to decide where he wants
to put his pieces
so that's why king j8 is such a big move
or
prophylactic as you will rook b1
a5 le pulasku wanted to go for b4 brakes
but
shock says no way
it ain't happening today bishop b5
okay so if you look at this position
you might be wondering who's having the
better chances
would it be white or black
well for that you always have to check
the middle of the board
and as you can tell it is black
who's controlling the most important
squares
there is a knight firmly positioned in
the middle of the board
and the c pawn is stopping any counter
d4 moves
trying to challenge that not to mention
the e pawn's a weakness
by the way in case of knight e5
there will be some splendid
sacrificial ideas for black
in the face of knight takes f4 if you
take here
wait does this even work
rook takes there is possibly queen c4
b5 queen b5 knight d4
or knight takes f takes
queen e3 now this is
probably still surviving
for white but already kind of scary so
it's not something you would go after
so already you can see you make one
false move
and your position might just crumble
should be
five knight e7 now if knight e5 would be
happening
this time there is knight takes e3 d
takes and you have to part with either
your queen
or the game after queen takes h2 like if
you go here
the screen takes h2 checkmate and it's
game over
so even though lopelasco isn't quite
lost yet
he has to tread carefully and there
could be
a trouble bruin now anywhere you put
that knight knight takes e3
will be on top rook fd1
knight f6 again using the fact that he
has
everybody lined up on the d file
bishop f1 knight g4 by the way
instead of rook fd1
if lupuna sku was vigilant enough in his
defenses
he would have realized he can go some
like rook f2
over defending the d2 square maybe even
move the rook to g2
and then in the long run you may even
try to expose that king on g8
that would have been a little bit more
of a thematic way
of playing combining defensive ideas
with more aggressive ones
so d1 knight f6
bishop f1 knight g4
again not necessarily the best move but
it's a very good human move
by mamedyarov he
is hinting at threats on h2
and lupulescu will also have to be on
the lookout
of knight takes c3 and just
watch in case of b4 there's captures
captures captures you can't really
capture here
because of that very idea of knight
takes c3
so the way shock is playing this game
is of a boxer not necessarily packing
punches
but pushing the opponent down
and next to the wall just making sure
that there is not enough space for
maneuvering for the opponent
so here the pulaski goes h3 but
h3 is sort of
a concession if you guys can tell me
that'd be great so let's just
stop here and realize what could be
the downside of pushing that pawn what
will be the difference
from the previous position where the
pawn was on
h2 instead of h3
there is a big difference there
is a big big difference and
that sort of has to do with the pawn
structure
that g3 pawn was well guarded earlier
but after you moved it move the h-bond
that is
you will have a constant weakness on g3
and he did not know that will
be the end-all be-all of the whole game
at f6 d3
and now you are going to see how
mamadyarov will consequently
shift his attention from the d-pawn
to the g-pawn knight c6
rookie one queen g7 already
pointing at the soft spot on g3 saying
hey man
that is something you've got to deal
with
it's an important pawn you got to deal
with it
queen f2 all right so
so far so good bye mommy
although lupulescu is defending very
well he is guarding the g
pawn everything seems to be fine
there is going to be that king h to move
so white is not at all losing on the
spot
so it's black we need to come on in
and put even more pressure on the g
pawn if we can how could we go about
that
so right now we only have a queen
attacking the jeep on
that definitely not going to make it
rain
so our rooks are basically
out of a job they're staring at a d-pawn
that is niftily defended by that bishop
on f1
we're definitely not going to win it
so they're looking for something to do
king h8 getting that rook to g8
shifting gears and going on the g file
trying to do their best to
pass the test
king h2 rook g8 now
all of these moves that we're looking at
are very sudden and surprising
because they're not your
bam bam bam bam bam move where
muhammad yarov is just crashing through
all these moves are prophylactic kind of
anticipating
action knight g4
was a probing idea but then he
anticipated all of the moves
happening and when king 88 rook g8
immediately going after the g-pawn
we bishop e2
knight d5
again activating the knight and this
is what makes super grand masters
so scary good at this game they make
sure they occupy
the most important squares and if they
do their chances of succeeding just
rises to the maximum
now lupulescu played bishop f1
and after this la this move
his life turned into a misery from a fun
one
so it is black to move and
unleash the worst for
white
so black has a very very very strong
move
if you were following the trajectory of
the game
it won't be too difficult to find
was very consequent he went for the
direct attack of the
d-pawn then he shifted his attention
to the g-file so all was
pushed on the file and now he's going to
shift his attention to the g
file
what would be the move and what is the
idea behind that move
exactly e5
and that's actually the beauty of
shakhma medyarov's game he spawns
these very creative solutions
that others often miss it has to do
with his innate talent plus
his attitude
and fondness of complicated positions
now he was known to play all these
binoni kings indian structures
and there you have to be creative in
order to succeed
so when i saw this position
i was a hundred percent sure and certain
that shaq wouldn't miss e5 because this
is
his style of play going after
the g pawn that way f takes
rook g6
going over for the g3 pawn and suddenly
there's nobody who can defend it if you
go g4 that's just getting
captured and with your king this breezy
add in the open not
being covered by guardian pawns
it is more likely to perish this game
so the only move that lupulescu try is
knight h4
seemingly threatening to both take on f5
and take on g6
rook takes g3 fearless
and in the game lupulescu played pawn
to d4 but the big question really is
what should black do in the case of
knight to takes
f5 what would be black's response
and obviously shakhma mego wouldn't have
played this move if he didn't see the
answer
this is a spectacular move that
wins on the spot but it is
very nice and nuanced
so whenever you're trying to find
a brilliant winning move you should
always
envision the square you will
end up checkmating on kind of using
the dream technique you want to envision
in your brain and your mind where you
want
that mate to happen which square will be
the one
where the mate will land on
and once you get that you're probably
going to find
the move well wasn't played by shah
but was intended to play by shah
rook f3 rook f3
and the square where the mate would land
is obviously on g1 because of this
bishop's
unfortunate placement the screen g1 and
the king can't go anywhere
there and that is a sad
sad news and
it'll be pretty pretty nasty by the way
there is no
knight takes g7 because of rook takes f2
check
there is a knight and king under attack
and if white goes king g1
obviously you don't take on g7 you just
move the rook away
if they want to pin all those guys
you capture you can't take it
if e4 well no worries
you're gonna take on g2 and have
a winning position and now
white's position quickly crumbles
d4 queen g5
knight g2 c takes
he takes and the last
touch by shah proms resignation from
lupulescu
so it's black to move and win
this one is a pretty one although
not as hard as the rook f3 find
so as c9 takes d4 being mentioned but
what if i just capture that
back what would be
the issue over there
if knight takes d4 would be captured
what is the problem with that
and that takes d4 and by the way zuna
takes d4
lupulescu did resign but
the reason there is no capture
it's not rook takes h3 because the king
could run to g1
but the idea of rook takes g2 here
here and the unlikely
but pretty queen g3 checkmate so that is
the reason
after knight d4 the pulaski
resigned so this was the very first game
by mamedyarov like very first
win and now you're going to see him take
on
levon arunian with the white pieces
and you're going to see
a similar attitude
yet a little bit less provocative
so let's take a look at that one let's
take a look
at that game by mama jarov
where he is actually not going to be
too aggressive fairly solid but then we
when he spots the right moment he takes
his chances
so this is the next game mama jarov is
placing
playing levon and this was not the
greatest time for levon
as he has been already kind of
struggling in the event
so d4 again chakriar is aiming for a
slower game not trying to
trade off and get a fighting position
not f3 knight c3
check e3 a very topical line
in the ragosa bishop b4 is known to be
the ragosan variation
and what shock is saying after this
check knight c6 your pawn on c7
is blocked off and you won't have an
easy time
moving it forward which is a typical
plan
if you do not know oftentimes
black would be aiming to undermine right
center with this move c7 to c5
and get some active play on
white queen side when shock goes for
queen a4
he makes sure that levon doesn't get any
direct attacking chances
castles bishop d2 d
takes bishop takes bishop d6
and this sort of have a feel of the
queen's gambit
queen's gambit accepted roulty
used to have very similar positions and
if that name doesn't ring a bell to you
he was a prominent grandmaster in
the 90s and was famously
the second of vladimir kramnik in his
match
versus kasparov
so here white goes for queen c2
e5 trying to open it up
and i always talk about this but i think
it's worth repeating
if your opponent's king is in the center
don't feel shy to open up the position
and that is exactly what levon does he
goes for e5 immediately
trying to expose chakriar's king
e5 detects knight takes
bishop takes e5
now if white could just start
rolling those pawns with e4 f4 and e5
this would be a position considered to
be strategically won
by white
so shock attempts f4
now here comes the dilemma for
levon how to react
if he relaxes too much
as we said the e pawn might just roll to
e5
and it is a strategical loss there's no
coming back from it
with the bishop so bad on c8 and passive
that's unlikely to be enough counter
play for levon
so levon takes on c3 bishop takes c3
and that on the surface looks like a
horrible decision but
in fact is the right move by lavon so
far
he's saying yes you're going to get the
bishop pair
but that will only benefit you in the
long term but in the short term
i can take advantage of the fact that
your king is still stuck in the middle
let's try to channel our inner lev
arunians
and try to find the most aggressive move
that we can
possibly play here as black
try to find an aggressive move that sort
of keeps shock skiing
in the center
knight g4
very good so there is no castling
because it runs into all kinds of
pins and attacks it's a family fork as
well
so that is no good so nigey for his very
forcing
by levon doesn't let shock go
castle and consolidate
has to go bishop d4 c5
again forcing the bishop away
rookie 8 hitting the spawn
now even though
shah also got a pawn it kind of
misplaced the bishop
and now levon has ample play
against that weakness not to mention
that king in the center
so shock decides to go for safety
and castle here
and interestingly enough lavone's next
move
is a mistake queen signed castling is
not a great idea
because it's not usually accepted by the
rules of chess
there is still a queen guarding that
square
so you cannot do that
so interestingly enough levon should
have gone b6
when sometimes so eventually that bishop
could show up on the long diagonal
and be quite strong
but instead he got a little bit
impatient and took on e3
instead bishop takes rook takes e3
the difference the bishop is still very
much
passive on c8 and as long it's stranded
there
the rook on a8 will be a prisoner as
well
so it's a common technique in these type
of positions
to liquidate all your opponents
good pieces and then
go after some weaknesses but first off
let's try to pinpoint levon's weakest
link in his position
because that will be very very important
his back rank is obviously super duper
weak
but in order to get a back rank mate you
gotta get
some people close to the back rank
and so therefore he played the rookie
one now there was another square that i
was hoping to hear about
and that's the f7 pawn like
traditionally
the f7 and its mirror pawn on f2 are the
weakest links in chess
and if you ever played any sort of
gambit
scotch gambit king's gambit what have
you
you notice how easy it is to attack that
pawn and maybe even just deliver a
checkmate
so the reason why shock played rookie
one
she could double it up get ready for
that intrusion
and then there is that back rank idea
that bite has been dreaming of
rook takes e1 rook takes c1
now we have some threats and now lavon
is by no means losing
but his pieces are so sort of jumbled up
and still on the eighth grasping for
some
air so it goes bishop d7
but bishop d7 is already kind of
suspecto
mariaro pounces at this chance i mean
literally pounces goes queen b3
not only hitting the f7 pawn
but hitting the b-pawn as well
the typical double attack where
you're facing very many or sometimes
too many issues queen f6
you take that pawn you take
that pawn on b7
queen d4 check king h1
rookie 8
and on the surface everything's all
right
for levon
there are plenty of weaknesses the
bishop and the pawn is being attacked
it doesn't seem like anything bad can
happen here
but in comes shakhma medyarov's
fantastic
spotted idea so it is
chakriar a vite to move and
win the game
so remember even if there are not many
pieces left
the back rank still can remain an issue
so the first move is obviously takes
bishop t c8 now we've got a couple of
things to deal with
one of them is queen f4 the other nun is
taking
and we also have our our back rank
issues
so our next move have to be forcing
and has to answer to all of those
questions
and indeed it is bishop to except seven
now what happens in case of bishop a
takes f7 it's not the move
played by levon but the critical
question
what if they just accept the sacrifice
what if they just do so
queen c8 yes
bishop e8 and queen takes c8 back rank
checkmate
so if your opponent doesn't really
create
luft with h6 or g6
oftentimes you do run into ideas such as
this one
and that's just about it you can't
stop that bishop takes f7
and this was a rude awakening for levon
where he actually thought he was very
close to equalizing
he almost did but he missed this idea of
bishop takes f7
king f8 but you still got questions to
answer
and that's actually the toughest part of
chess
everybody is very very much
aware of tactical ideas but it's never
the end of the game
the game and the last phase just begins
you have to proceed to check out you
have to make sure
you don't forget about your opponent's
threats and
believe it or not the biggest reason
everybody is
losing when they see these tactics is
that they
do not care or do not pay attention to
opponents threats
so what is levon threatening right now
it's obviously the back rank but after
king f8 bishop takes f7
becomes an issue as well
and with that you're kind of finding
your own thread
and finding your own way of succeeding
now here the right move is bishop b3
over defending the d1 square
and defending against bishop f7 so
the goal and the most important part
that you always have to
look out for is your opponent's threats
they're sometimes even more important
than your own queen c5
again quite a deadly threat
queen d5 so a little bit of attacking
the queen and also sending up queen g8
check bishop d1
takes now he realizes
that there is no mate there as long as
he can get the queen
to a7m back
check here takes
h5 and h3
bishop c6
check king h7 queen f7
again still watching out for trickies
if you're not paying attention levon can
go here
here well king h2 is mate
but mostly bishop takes g2 check it's
that easy
you missed a half a move
and your advantage is gone and it's
already unclear
so bishop b3 queen f7
check queen c5 check
g6 queen f6 so most of
shock's move is to provoke some
weaknesses around the king
and then to consolidate taking away
all those tricky checks from levon
ship d7 h4 setting up the mating idea
i mean mating ideas are great but you
still have to be very vigilant
queen c7 queen c8 check
green f7 and here levon resigned
because in case of king h6 there's queen
g8
with a mass trade on that side of the
board and it is just game over
that chakri are having two pawns on the
roll
on the queen side there's absolutely
nothing that really can happen there so
the last game that i wanted to
touch upon is the game between
fabiano caruana
and chakrian moment yarrow so he was
already on a streak
he's won the first game versus lupulusku
then another one
against level naronjan and now he's
placing
fabiano and
there are some people who would take it
easier
but shaw kind of felt hey this is the
right moment
i'm in a good shape let's just go
on and try to go for it
knight c6 and somewhat surprisingly
chakriar plays knight f6
instead of his trust
trusted and well tried variation
in the open spanish which he played
quite frequently
and of course he played the bishop e7
mainlines as well
namely the breyer but this time he goes
for knight f6
and this surprises fabiano
goes d3 and knight c3
but much to fabiano's surprise
he's gonna get surprised again
this position most everybody goes d6
but instead chakra goes knight d4
which is the fourth fifth most popular
move in the position
so it comes as a shocker for
fabi and
that is a very good sign for mamedyarov
he's going to get a fighting game
that fabi sort of half out of
preparation
and with plenty of pieces on the board
so i know berlin gets a bad rep but if
you look at this one
the fact that there's all of the pieces
on the board
does mean that there's still something
to play for
what's boring is more of the end game
that
they played previously these positions
can get very rich and lively
bishop a4 c6
castle d6 just consolidating
and surprisingly enough we are
transposing right back
into four knight's opening knight takes
d4
h3 and shock's next move
is astounding it's just an
astounding move it's not nobody even
thought about it for a split second that
this
move can get there
now if there would be a pawn take
on e5 then black could go c6
castles and black will get
quick development for the sacrificed
pawn that is the critical question
but fabiano this time did not want to
get into complications which could be
something along these lines
of taking on f7 giving up the two pieces
for the rooks but white gets
plenty of pawns instead event for this
one
and here shaw unleashes
he's trusted and tried g5 move
quite a spectacular one
as white has committed early with
castling
black is fancying his chances with g5 g4
and you'd be saying oh this idea was
never seen before
now think again this very same idea
was played by shah but in a different
variation
i do want to show it to you so it's the
same in the spanish
a6 bishop a4
d6 castles
g5 this has been shock momentum's big
big win
in this line this g5 idea
has been recurring in his games with
great success
the idea being very similar
trying to put pressure on the king side
this time trying to dissuade
white from getting the d4 move in
but back to the game to g5
here fabiano had one move that he could
he could have tried to play here but
didn't play when fortnight defi could
have been for knight d5
because this pin on the king on e8
and it's just not going to be able to
capture if you go b5
white can't capture on f6 and bishop b3
and then you're not having the best of
positions
92 but he's sort of missing his chances
bishop b6 c3
so fabiano decides to go for the slow
route
but in this case the center is locked
down
there's literally no advantage for
either side
but shock has a little bit more pressure
on the king side therefore shock's
advantage
is kind of apparent now
shock's next move is rook g8 he goes
on the attack on the g file
he's not playing g4 know that he doesn't
play g4
he knows that the threat is bigger than
the execution
and prepares that idea now fabiano
understands that he's in big trouble
he can just go bishop e3 he's just gonna
get rolled
with g4 g3 so instead
he goes d4 but d4 is sort of admitting
that he's having the worst position and
now the position
will be sort of crumbling
bishop c2 d5
takes takes d takes e5
so now black has the advantage has the
bishop pair
what should black be aiming in this case
so that's an important situation you get
good positions shock get good
position fabiano often gets good
positions but then you have to decide
what to do with it that's the big
question what to do with your advantage
so so far you've got
a solid well the pawn can be a nuisance
on g5 but has a good
pawn on e4 there is a target on e5
we can't go after but not just that
has the bishop pair the bishop pair
to work with so in fact he is
not going to evade the trade of the
queens
he is going to enforce it and says hey
if i can open it up for these bishops on
c8 and b6
my attack is just going to grow
so in the end game if you already have
the bishop pair that is something you
can milk and use
for your advantage you have no reason to
keep the queens on the board
in fact fabi would be the one benefiting
as mamadirov's king is in the middle so
g4
g3 the idea what i'm saying he's trying
to open it up
knight d4 bishop d8
and these long range pieces
can attack from anywhere from on the
board bishop d
is a very nice move and now you can see
one just has too many weaknesses upon on
e5
a pawn on h4 just way too many
rook takes rook g4
bishop g5 and bishop g5 is a form of a
desperado
by fabiano he
is trying to trade off the bishop
pair and in that case he'll be down a
couple of pawns
but at least he's not going to be
constantly under attack
take take king e7 rook t1
bishop d7 e6 takes
g6 takes but this is already two pawns
and that's one two one pawn too many
here
all that said because of the relative
passivity of this bishop on d7
you can consider a
fine maneuver here can go
knight c2 go knight t3 and
hope for a blockade now cause and might
not be
on your side but maybe luck will be and
you manage to hold this end game even
though
black is up to pawns it's not so
easy to play
break through this blockade that is it's
not
likely be an easy task he goes knight b3
and misplaces the knight which is a
little bit of a problem
e5 knight a5 rook b8
b4 he's trying to go for counter play
instead of
passive blockade but this knight will
eventually
actually find itself trapped
rogue g3 the c pawn is falling for a not
so
valuable e pawn rook takes c3
and b6 and this is what i'm talking
about you are losing your knight there
and that's why i felt that the knight on
e3 would have been
a little bit more stubborn probably
still very close to losing
but more stubborn knight takes bishop
takes
here rook check king e6
check here king g1 and
the final touch by mamedyarov here is
very beautiful
this one's a very very beautiful move
by mamedyarov sort of
just simplifying into a clear positional
advantage
from a position where fabiano could at
least
try to put up some fight
notice that this rook on c7 is
undefended and momentarily is going to
use that
to its benefit because rook h1 check
you have to take bishop takes g2
now shock was up a piece already so this
way he's just giving it back for a pawn
rook takes rook takes c7 and now
the coast is cleared white is down
only one pawn after rook takes g6
but look at the difference between the
kings this kings is
oceans away from the right part of the
board
and the a and b pawn are likely to fall
a5 continued
takes takes king takes rookie 1
rook g5 and it is game over
because the king is just too far away
and the b-pawn is just going to be
coasting down the board and there's
nothing that they can
do about it so
this was the lecture on mamedyaro's
winning streak and how he managed to win
the first tournament of the year with
the crunches tour
thank you so much for watching and
goodbye
[Music]
you